افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد خمسه اشخاص
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال في قصر قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف منزل عائله الحواجري بمخيم
النصيرات وسط قطاع غزه بينما نجحت فرق
الانقاذ في انتشال اطفال من تحت
[موسيقى]
الركابي
خلص اهدي اهدي
اه
خلص ايش
عمليه خلص شاطه هيني عندك هين
[موسيقى]
عند خذ
الجد من عندك تطلع عليها
بس كويس انت يلا وال انا
طالع خليكي يا عم ما تتحركيش تتحركيش خليك
شويه ايش يا ساره تمام تمام ساره ساره انت
بخير ساره
ساره شار
اك قوم يا عم هيني عندك انا يا اختي تعالي
ه تعال ار كويس
انت من الشارع
ساره ساره متاج وين رامل عليها رمل مش
عارفه مين بقى
مع الله يوفقكم طول شيماء
طلعوها خلص اهد اهد صحيح طيب شاء الله
صحيح
تعبيه جاهز
جاهز دو بدي الف رجلها بدي الف رجلها
استن بدي احطلك الحماله هها يا
بهاء خل واحد يجي ه من تحت من فوق احسن
واحد من تحت وسلم واحد من
ه
الجوال
يلا يا ح ياخد مني طيب اناخ منك يا
عم مني من
ه